oh so I'm Victor and today I want to
give you an advanced talk showing
different patterns and techniques we can
use to build applications within TRX and
I was I used to be at Google where I
worked on a lot of key component of
angular and I used to blog at visa
Afghan woodcomb we can still go and
check out a lot of good angular content
and some time ago Jeff Gross who was
also on Angela team and I left Google to
start our company called Narwhal
where we help large teams build
ambitious projects with angular and
these days have log add blog dot Narwhal
that I'll check it out as well so check
out our site to see what we do how we
work check out our blog and our Twitter
to find a lot of free high-quality a
killer content also we have these three
books we wrote about the framework one
on the framework itself another one on
the router the last one on upgrading
angularjs one apps to to angular so
check them out as well so today I'm
going to cover the following as I will
start with a short overview of in grx
and why we should use it and what
challenges will face if we start using
it so the target audience for this talk
is someone who is at least a little bit
familiar with the 80s behind grx or read
acts or any state management system that
works in this way so it won't be an
in-depth explanation I'll just give you
an overview so you sort of have a
starting point then I will switch now
talk about actions which is the core
primitive that we use when I build
applications using interacts and
particular I will talk about these three
categories of actions we often see on
your item Gerak's applications then I
will cover the store which is the most
interesting bit overriding applications
with interaction angular and I will talk
about how we decide what how we process
actions how to transform actions how we
compose all these building blocks
together to implement our applications
so a big part of this talk is based on
this wonderful book the title is very
scary and enterprise integration
patterns but this is the best book on
messaging I know it's a wonderful book
and at least a half or a third of it
applies to
to front end and to interact and to
build in angular applications within TRX
so I highly recommend you to check this
book out okay so what is it in GX and
why we should use it so programming
isn't your ex it essentially programming
with messages so instead of updating
this tape in place what we do is we or
components rather they send messages or
they call action Zanjeer acts to express
some intense a.m. temp and the last
cycle of an action looks like this so we
start with the component the sender
start with creating an action and
filling it with data okay then the
component dispatches an action which
essentially adds it to the store that
then the action can be received and
processed and it can be processed in two
different ways the first one the
simplest one is that it can be processed
by the user and they reduce it with
asynchronous function taking the current
state of your application or subset of
your a subset of the state of your
application and taking some sort of
action and creating a new state out of
the current state and the action
basically it applies that action to the
state so we see an example of reducer on
this line which takes a list of two do's
and it handles one action which is the
add to do action so it takes that action
and if it happens you know it creates a
new list of to dos within you to do edit
okay and then it returns that list if we
receive a different action we're going
to return the default state the one from
the previous location so let the easiest
way to or the simplest way to process
actions the answer one is then the
actions can be processed by effects
classes and the effects class take the
actions object which is essentially an
observable of all actions flowing
through your application okay so
everything that happens of value in your
application will go through the
observable so these things class taps
into it so it can take a subset you know
of that observable and it basically
handles execute necessary side effects
to make sure your application you know
works so often in reality many
interactions require us to have both an
effect was an reducer to execute those
interactions here for example we see
a very simple example when we receive it
to do and the few thing we are doing in
the face class is that we are positive
that to do so we are saving it on the
back end and once that to do is saved
what we are doing is we are dispatching
a new action code to do edit with a
payload and then I will reduce there
you'll get to do edit and we'll modify
the local state so we have a single
interaction which is we are going to add
a to-do to the list of reduce an
interval involves having two actions
once the default action goes to the back
and the second one updates a lot of
state so once we're done with this once
we obtain the local state what we want
to do is we want to often the air so
they reflect the state change and the
component itself in the template so
that's what we're doing here the
constructor we are selecting the state
of the state of seduce all this do from
the store so we get this observable and
any time we enter to do remove what to
do or update and existent to do that
observer will emit a new value a new
list of to dos which is and that list
will be displayed by this component okay
so graphically it looks like this okay
not what I told you since she looks like
this the component dispatches selection
which goes to the store and then in the
store it's processed by effects by
effect classes which often involves
deciding on how to process an action and
transforming an action then we execute
all the necessary side effects and
finally the reducer will create a new
state which is the component will
receive okay that's in a notch or how
interacts works and if you don't use
indirect I recommend to check route now
let's look at every part of this picture
at this diagram in greater detail okay
the first part is action so an action is
what we dispatch when we want to express
our intent essentially the message took
is a synonym for message and in Gerak's
in the directs the action has two parts
the first one is the type and the type
of just a string that you can assign to
an action and a second part is a payload
the payload is some extra information we
need to be able to process this action
as with most messaging systems and a
directs the messaging system
actions that you fight in other words
they are represented as concrete objects
we can pass around and store and a lot
of good staff that nginx brings comes
from this property that they are if I
okay so in genetics is a very simple
library and as you can see doesn't
actually make a lot of assumptions about
what your actions are I would it contain
it doesn't really care how you define
those types you know it needs to be a
string that's it it doesn't care how you
find those payloads okay so enjoy x does
not care it doesn't care how we
construct those actions okay so I tend
to do it in place like this just in the
component itself but you know if you
feel like it you can extract the
construction of an action in terms of
the factory function okay and it's
useful when you want to sort of enforce
that certain invariance hold so if you
want to go and key that factory function
it's a good way to do it so so engine X
doesn't impose sort of any constraints
on Elections apart from the perhaps you
should have these two fields but if you
start using in GX you know after maybe a
few days you'll find out that not all
actions are alike there a certain
categories of actions fall into they're
actually three categories so actions can
be further roughly divided that these
three categories the first one it
commands the documents and events what's
interesting is that the same critical
ization works really well for most
messaging systems so you know which
tells to me that there is something
fundamental about dividing your actions
of messages into these three groups so
when dispatch to the command what we do
in essentially we are trying to sort
like invoke a message yes dispatch it
Achmed is similar to invoke in a method
our intent is to tell some part of the
system somewhere else to do something
okay and usually the single place there
is a single handler when processing that
command and you often get reply we may
expect reply maybe it's a value maybe
it's an error no that's reasonable and
load commands are and I prefer to name
my commands in this fashion like a verb
and you know now like other to do
documents is different because dispatch
in document is essentially tell the
system that this entity has been updated
okay that's it we do not get to reply up
to this
document and there might be more than
one place most one handler processing
this document she's less procedural okay
and finally I tend to name my documents
using just plain nouns finally an event
this mention event basically tells the
system that the term change has occurred
and similar to documents events are
often handled by more than one place in
our application by muslimin handler and
events do not provide the response so is
like fire-and-forget kind of situation
and I named my invents in this in this
way so something happened okay
so often we need to use more than one
action to implement an interaction as I
already mentioned here for example now
when we know how we can categorize this
action we see the destroys thing we are
doing is we're dispatching the ad to do
command that command is handled by an
offense class and then once we persist
up on the back end the offence class is
going to dispatch that to do edit event
which is going to handled by our reducer
okay so one interaction is both a
command and an event okay so those are
the most obvious differences okay we
either this expects reply or not or we
have one or many handlers so I I'm
prefer using that naming convention I
showed you because it goes a long way to
show you what is what you know so I
recommend you to either adopt this
convention or have your own but we can
also have application specific
conventions in addition to that one for
example we can say that all documents
must have an ID of the entity you know
all events must have a timestamp no
corresponding to when the event occurred
so in other words we can impose our own
schema on a certain action category the
last thing I won't talk about the
Guardian actions it is a deal request
apply because I showed you or as I told
you then when we dispatch a command we
sometimes may expect a reply the
dispatch method however doesn't read
your name okay so how do we get that
reply here for example I have a single
component that manages our to do it has
a delete method and say we want to
confirm when the user clicks on delete
button whatever that we want to confirm
that this particular do should be
deleted so we need to ask the user
we cannot do it locally so we cannot
just show the dialogue here in this
component because these separations are
continuation itself may result for
example in a URL change or may result in
other non local effects and when you're
using genetics no local effects have to
be handled by effects classes so we have
to go through the same mechanism as I
showed you we have to dispatch an action
and then somehow get a reply okay so
what is going to happen in reality here
is that when we despite this action we
want to get the boolean back yes in the
NIT what is going to happen at
Summerfest was going to pick it up it's
going to change the URL it's going to
display some other component and at some
point you know it would get this result
that boolean is going to store it
somewhere in this state because once
again when using grx any non-local state
is store stores in the store in the
stores State okay so what we need to do
now after we dispatch it we need to just
query the state so here I am using
select again to query the subset of the
application state and no time isn't it
to do ID to find the right response okay
but where ID is used in this particular
fashion a code often referred to as
correlation 80s because we use them to
correlate our requests and our replies
okay and usually a 90kg like a to do ad
works really well for this kind of stuff
but when it doesn't and sometimes it
doesn't we can always generate a
synthetic one like this so here we
generate an ID which is distinct from
the to do idea okay so in addition to
just support request replies correlation
I need to say do correlation idea which
is very very useful can be used for
other coordination related tasks for
example if you want to make sure the
complex interaction that for example it
needs multiple action to dispatches
multiple actions is fully complete we
can assign the same correlation ID to
all of those actions and then wait for
all of them to complete okay ok store so
we've learned about the three categories
of actions we can dispatch now more
interesting bit okay of the set up the
store the store is but the bulk of the
logic of your application is contained
when you use indirect to build
applications and if you watch talks on
in genetics or in acts what you'll find
is that most developers tend to focus on
the reducers okay on the reducer bit of
the store I do not and I I think that
they do society very easy to understand
this thinking as simple functions take
the state take an action in turning
state there is nothing there to discuss
you know just it's trivial there is that
easy there that's simple to think about
because the complexity of our
application was moved as the reducers do
not have the complex part of application
it's somewhere else and in case you
can't direct that someone else is
effects classes because the face classes
in journals do manage a synchronicity
they manage coordination okay they
calculate multiple processes they talk
to the backend there's a harder part
okay that's what we need to understand
really well and what's interesting here
that my experience from of working on
messaging systems on the backend and
plans really well to effects classes
okay so let's look at how we can apply
some of it in general if X wants what we
do can be categorized into three in
three ways philsie decide how to process
the particular action then they
transform an action to some other form
which is easier to handle and finally
the perform side effect okay it is
useful to have this distinction in mind
and it's even better if you can express
on the code okay so let's examine each
of these blocks in detail so a lot of
what advanced classes do is they decide
how to process an action okay and the
simplest way to do it the simplest
decider is the filtering decided okay it
is so common that in GX comes with a
special operator that implements it
called off type and it allows you to
select among all the actions in your
application sort of a subset of
all the action to a particular type okay
which is similar to essentially just
filter it by type the next one the next
common one is a Kuantan based designer
here essentially what we are doing is
we're taking an add to direction and we
are mapping it to either a pen to do or
insert to do depending on the content of
the page load okay that was called
content-based decider this makes sense
when a painting an insurgent actually
fundamentally different
not very differently so this example is
contrived obviously here may make a lot
of sense but in large apps and the real
apps that evolve over time these
situations occur very often isn't by
doing so we introduced in us 11
direction which can be useful for couple
of reasons you know because essentially
it decouples what we dispatch you know
the action we dispatch from what handled
elsewhere
okay the next designer which is common
is the quantex based designer so it uses
some information from the environment
itself from some injected entity instead
of the payload to decide what a
particular action should be mapped to
okay this is common as well when our
application has distinct workflows which
is a component dispatching that action
shouldn't know about the component
always dispatches one action and then
somewhere else here the context based
designer will decide what it actually
should be mapped to how should be
handled okay the next one is called a
splitter and what it does it takes an
action and maps it to an array of action
so it splits an action ok and it's
similar to speaking one method
intermountain methods okay
it allowed us to test every single
action dependently for example yes here
for example you probably won't would
like to test the add two direction
without worrying about logging the
opposite of splitter is the aggregator
okay what it does it takes an array of
actions and it maps at array in this
single action here for example we have
two actions to do edit and logged which
we assume events dispatched by the
actions we saw last time and we sort of
combine them and we use the result with
combination to create a new action had
to do completed okay
the aggregator is a little bit more
involved so let me walk you through
throw it line by line so here we have
some essentially odd for every add two
direction we are going to receive or we
are going to have to access back to do
edit unlocked okay like this so we're
using the actions observable here to get
the absorb of length one for each of
those actions and not we using the ID
the correlation ID here to select the
right action
and after that we're using the zip
operator to create a pair and we can use
this pair in order to to create a new
action out of the payloads of the action
stored in that pair okay it looks a
little bit involved you know how did it
go boosts the result of bullet periods
and so but we can extract it by defining
a very simple helper function so we can
always define a function it looks like
this and it will do the aggregation for
us okay so fundamentally it's not more
verbose and answer I decided so are the
Transformers over pod it happens to be
more variables because our eggshells
doesn't come with one does it for us
anyway
so these are the most common designers
we tend to see when we build our
applications with engine X the filtering
designer uses the action type you know
essentially to to process actions on the
other type the content based designer
uses the payload of an action to map one
action to another one the quantex base
designer uses the environment itself to
map one action to another one
the splitter maps in action to an array
of actions and the aggregate it does the
opposite takes in the directions okay
it's one action out of it okay so the
next building block of our phase classes
our action transformers okay and the
purpose of a transformer is to take an
action and massage it will transform
with an introduction
it was very Safari the two most common
ones the first one is a contest and
reacher
the corner takes an action take some
information from elsewhere and adds it
to the action and emits a new one okay
this example is very basic because
essentially we just have the current
user available synchronously already
they injected a more increased example
would be maybe fetch in some information
from the backend and add in that
information to the payload okay so the
dispatcher of the action wouldn't know
that we need to face facts
transformation and the handler of the
action would know either we have an
intermediate step that will do it for us
the the other one which is very common
is a normal answer is when we take
multiple actions are somewhat similar
you know and we've mapped them we
transform them into action of the same
type this is common if you have for
example an upgrade project if you are
moving in English as one application to
aim to an angle application and
you just cannot dispatch the same action
because of you know you don't have the
right data whatever
so you just purchase similar actions and
then do normalize we'll make sure to
normalize all those actions to the same
type so you can have a single handler
working again this example is obviously
contrived but hopefully the idea is
clear so these are some of the most
common building blocks we use to
implement the logic and our store as we
have five comma designers to common
transformers have the reducer which
computes a new state take the current
stable creates any one and we have sine
of X which is essentially where we talk
to the backend you know store stuff some
or print stuff the console the best part
of this bill about these building blocks
is that they compose video okay so let's
look at one example so here we have a
pretty complex interaction handling
handled by and GX essentially what
happens here is we're taking the absorb
of all that should happen in our
application we have filtering it that's
how we usually start handling actions
then we split it into two separate
actions then for the top one we are
going to use a quantum base decided to
design how to handle it the bottom one
is simpler then we execute also needed
side effects only aggregate the result
and then we give this aggregation this
new action to the reducer which will
create a new state which our component
where is he okay so this is very like
very very complex in reality you know
what you usually see you stuff like this
okay very very simple but the point here
is that it is compliant but it's still
composed to the same building blocks we
can still the reason to talk about this
example naming info where because I have
this language and to make one thing
clear about advocating you to split your
effects across the five different
classes because that would be nonsense
whatever I like that the last thing I'd
like you to do what I am advocating here
is to is having a clear mental model how
your fact passes work and having a
language you can use to talk about them
with your co-workers here for example we
have a very very complex action howling
strategy I'm not worried about to call
too much the point being is that we're
doing a lot here and we're doing all of
it in one place in a single effects
class but even though we're doing all of
it in one
place in one class we can still annotate
and see that every look our language our
pattern language applies to this example
as well so we can see that in this
offense class we are starting with a
filtering decider then we use the
enricher than the splitter the condom
will set on the splitter and then that's
how we create the first effect and we
can see just by looking at visually the
difference the fact that at the do
effect doesn't actually execute side
effects and the answer to effects the
only thing they do is they execute side
effects it isn't interesting because
this property alone tells us that these
effects the first one and the other two
should be tested and thought off in a
very different ways okay another
important thing that it to get there you
know so we can have it in one place and
only when one of those pieces gets too
complicated we can extract it and test
separate the text class or inter
separate effect without affecting any of
all clients and without affecting any
other handler all right so let's review
what we've learned we've learned a few
things okay the first thing we've
learned is that that's how jerax works I
figure the best way to represent it
graphically I sense you have component
dispatch connections and then we have
the store which you know process those
actions decides how to do transforms and
execute side effects and use it use it
to create new state snapshots consumed
with a component we've learned that even
doing GX sort of very loose it doesn't
impose any categorization on your
actions it is useful to divide them into
these three categories commands
documents and events and we've learned
that the difference this my commands may
expect a reply and I usually almost
always handled by single handler and
we've learned that for example events
and documents do not expect a reply we
cannot expect a reply one of dispatch an
event and they might be most Matt
handler we've learned over a rather we
looked at the cool building blocks of
assembling our store there are five
comma deciders - two comma transformers
have the reducers and have the side
effects and the best part of it is that
we can you know compose them really well
and implement even very very complex
interactions like this one
using the same building block the same
primitives and talk about them use the
same language and we're also blown that
I'm not advocating to you know having 15
different classes to implement a simple
interaction the too much boilerplate to
another price that you know should be in
one place if it works but you can still
use the language you can still expressed
in the code even though it's in the
single class or within a single effect
you know the separation can still be
clear so the goal of this is not to make
lots of classes but rather have
meaningful conversations with each other
and then once we have complex pieces
that get out of hand we can extract
those as needed without affecting any of
the clients also all this is based on
this book and if you are using ng rx or
if you use redux let's say this is the
book to read pretty much every single
complex thinking about using indirect or
redux is handled or written about in
this book so check it out okay cool
you can check out our site and check out
our blog and get one of those books
thank you
[Applause]